We're going to make
general Rmax algorithm and
it's going to be really simple
because it's going to be an awful lot
like the Rmax algorithm
we already looked at.
>> Good.
>> So I copied over the Rmax
algorithm that we had before.
And it went like this,
we're going to keep track of the MDP.
Which is to say we're going to have
an estimate of the transitions and
rewards for all the state action pairs.
Any unknown state action pair,
we're going to assume has the reward of
Rmax and then a self loop, so we can
just get like aahh for a long time.
Then we actually build that MDP,
we solve that MDP and we take
an action from the optimal policy with
respect to that MDP that we solve.
The only difference is going to
be this notion of unknown.
And the idea is that we're
going to have some parameter.
Call it C, that state action pair
is unknown if it's been visited or
if we've tried it out
fewer than C times.
>> Okay, is that C different for
every state action pair?
>> That's a good question.
So I want to first give
the parametrized algorithm.
Then what we have to do is, if we're
going to say that this algorithm is
efficient, we have to derive some value
for C and show that it's not too big and
not too small but-
>> Just right.
>> Just right, yeah.
So the way that we're defining unknown
here is that we have some parameter C.
And we consider a state-action
pair SA unknown
if it was tried fewer than c times.
After that point then, we switch over
to the maximum likelihood estimate.
So, we've tried it c times,
and we saw we went
from state s with action
a to some state, S 53,
so if we did that some number of times.
If we only did that once, then we're
going to estimate a probability of 1
over c for getting that transition.
So this gives us a new estimate
of the transitions and
rewards based on the data
that we've actually gathered.
Okay.
So I just want to point out that
this is the Rmax algorithm we
used in the deterministic case, and
this very much is related to the hufting
bound estimate we used in the stochastic
non-sequential case in the bandit case.
Which is grafting
the two things together.